ah
[Música]
y han deseado ser una persona
completamente diferente a la que ven
reflejada
tal vez quitarse un poquito de grasa
unos centímetros más de altura ser más
guapas y guapos
a mí me ha pasado y desde que tengo
memoria enfrentarme a mi reflejo ha sido
una batalla en la que muchas veces
termine perdiendo
tal vez si a los 67 años el genio de la
lámpara no hubiera ofrecido a concederme
tres deseos sin pensarlo le habría
pedido que en primer lugar me quitara la
pancita un segundo que alargará mis
piernas y el tercero que me concediera
deseos ilimitados para continuar
cambiando cosas de mí
así es la jimena dieciséis años la tenía
en su inconsciente este deseo por ser
perfecta femenina amada
los deseos me siguieron hasta la
pubertad y todo se intensificó conforme
me creció el busto me llegó a la
menstruación y el mundo en el que había
crecido cambió al convertirme en una
señorita
y empecé a cuidar los escotes cómo me
sentaba y que compartía con el mundo
para no romper con el canon de la mujer
perfecta
sentía que mis amigos solo me veían como
jimena la chichona
y sabía que salir a la calle implicaba
aguantarse miradas chiflidos y los
famosos piropos y que mis amigas no
durarían en criticarme en cuanto no
estuviera con ellas
la neta me sentía estafado nadie me
había dicho que crecer significaría dos
horas viendo dietas mi mochila llena de
toallas porque nunca se sabe cuándo te
bajará
y sí
y me perdí porque nunca se sabe cuándo
te bajará o mi maestro de educación
física diciéndome que usaron brasier que
sostuviera mejor me gustó si no quería
que los niños tirarán baba cuando
corrían
me di cuenta que el cuerpo femenino es
un arma de doble filo porque podía usar
este pedazo de carne que me fue dado
para atraer a ciertas personas pero
también ser acosada por un cuerpo del
que no me podía deshacer
de acuerdo a la historiadora brum ver
como adolescentes muchas veces entramos
en crisis de angustia frente a nuestra
identidad y aspecto físico nuestra
conciencia aumenta o disminuye
dependiendo el encuadre social al que
pertenecemos
en mi caso ante el estado de conciencia
acerca del poder que tiene el cuerpo
femenino mi obsesión por ser perfecta y
tener este cuerpo perfecto incremento
justo en la etapa del florecimiento de
la pubertad y el autoconcepto
a los alumnos de primaria secundaria nos
dieron una plática de trastornos de
alimentación en la que entre otras cosas
nos mostraron fotos de chavas que
padecían de anorexia bulimia vigorexia
justo el cuerpo que yo estaba buscando
la plática tuvo efectos inesperados en
mí y algunas amigas cuerpos delgados
logrados con abstinencia de alimentos y
ejercicio en exceso me llevó a pensar
que esa era la solución ante mi
insatisfacción y tristeza
y mi madre ya había hecho una tesis
antes de como la publicidad afecta en
los trastornos de alimentación por lo
que yo ya tenía información de que eran
no era nada nuevo para mí para pesar de
eso yo le seguí
y ella siempre preocupada por mí a veces
un poco más de lo necesario me lleva al
nutriólogo y ahí fue donde las cosas
empeoraron porque empecé a hacer dietas
tener alimentos prohibidos y dejé de
escuchar a mi cuerpo tenía un hambre
voraz quería para darme mi alacena
completa empecé comiéndome cuatro
galletas extra o que no estaban
incluidas dentro de mi plan de
alimentación
pero conforme pasó el tiempo esas cuatro
galletas se convirtieron en un tubo más
una caja completa de barritas cereal pan
papas cualquier cosa que se cruzará en
mi camino y después de consumir
aproximadamente 1000 calorías en menos
de 40 minutos iba corriendo al baño a
vomitar
empecé metiendo mis cuatro dedos a la
boca pero se fue haciendo más fácil y
después un simple empujoncito
autoinducido era suficiente para sacar
toda la comida
comer sentirme llena y luego vacía en
una sensación de placer y plenitud por
el mayor placer eran los comentarios que
hacían mis amigos familiares y maestras
de ballet
qué guapa estás bajaste de peso y estás
haciendo lo que corpas tú tienes estos
comentarios me hacían seguir a pesar de
ya no tener fuerza para hacerlo
tras dos años de estar reproduciendo
este ciclo por lo menos cuatro veces al
día mi maestra de ballet se dio cuenta y
se preocupó por mis constantes permisos
para ir al baño y mi pérdida de peso por
lo que mis papás se enteraron y ahí
empezó la búsqueda por doctores terminé
en una clínica de trastornos de
alimentación en donde fui detectaba con
bulimia nerviosa y así sin más empecé mi
camino a la recuperación y años después
sigo luchando por esta que ha sido la
batalla más grande de mi vida
y digo que es una lucha porque sentía
que había 2 jiménez diciéndome que hacer
de un lado del ring tenemos a la jimena
que buscaba recuperarse amarse y
aceptarse tal cual es y pasarse por los
ovarios cualquier comentario que sean
respecto a su cuerpo
del otro lado del ring tenemos a la
jimena obsesionada con las dietas y el
ejercicio físico pero hambrienta por
comer y llenar sus vacíos la que me
decía pareces una vaca y nadie te va a
querer con esas lonjas
este jimena se estaba revelando en
contra de sus padres y cualquier
autoridad que le dijera que hacer
buscando a chavas delgadas en redes
sociales como tumblr y pasteles que no
podía comer en pintores
eso era para mí la bulimia un subir y
bajar un querer gritar pero no poder
hacerlo
técnicamente y de manera muy breve la
bulimia es un trastorno de alimentación
que entra dentro de los trastornos
mentales cara y caracterizado por la
ingesta de alimentos en desmedidas sin
forma sin control y después actitudes de
acciones compensatorias como es el
vómito el uso de laxantes o el ejercicio
otro trastorno conocido es la anorexia
dejar de comer por miedo a engordar y
otros menos conocidos como el trastorno
por atracón la ortorexia que es esta
obsesión por la comida sana y la
vigorexia obsesión por el ejercicio
físico
en méxico cada año se registran cerca de
20.000 casos de trastornos alimenticios
siendo los jóvenes de entre 15 y 19 años
de edad los más afectados esto
representa un aumento del 300% en tan
solo 20 años y algo que me llamó mucho
la atención es que de las personas que
se van a tratar los trastornos el 90%
son mujeres y sólo el 10% son hombres
estos números no pueden ser ignorados
porque es un tema del que necesitamos
hablar
y una de las razones por las que me
recuperé fue porque no le hice caso a mi
mamá cuando me dijo no hables de tu
bulimia te van a juzgar pues que me
juzguen si es necesario
no soy doctora psicóloga y no tengo
ningún estudio especializado en
trastornos de alimentación pero lo que
sí tengo son siete años viviendo con
esto y cuatro en recuperación por lo que
me gustaría darles cinco puntos y a
pesar de que no van a resolver el
problema por lo por lo menos nos van a
dar una idea de dónde estamos en primer
lugar decir soy bulímica no es una
grosería y hablar de trastornos de
alimentación no debería de ser
considerado tema tabú necesitamos crear
ambientes de confianza en uno notarán
menos o discriminen por ser diferente
muchas veces nos da miedo hablar de los
temas que no conocemos pero es por eso
que necesitamos informarnos y hacer que
los demás se sientan aceptados en
segundo lugar las personas no
despertamos un día y decimos antes no
soy quiero tener una anorexia osea no
simplemente es el camino que nuestra
mente va encontrando para llenar estos
vacíos y este deseo de ser aceptados
el tercer punto es que vivimos en el
oasis de las dietas simplemente abran
una revista a una página cualquier red
social y encontrarán un link o un
anuncio de la nueva e increíble dieta
que te hará bajar 10 kilos en dos
semanas
es momento de hacer la paz con la comida
no hay alimentos prohibidos todos
tenemos derecho a comer lo que se nos dé
la regalaba gana con moderación y
escuchando a nuestro cuerpo
cuarto punto
tenemos en nuestra mente impregnado lo
que es un cuerpo perfecto
yo les pregunto cuántas frases y fotos
no nos recuerdan día con día la
importancia del físico este cuerpo
delgado y atractivo
por mucho tiempo yo alimentaba mi
obsesión con estas imágenes hasta que
hace año y medio aproximadamente empecé
empecé a seguir a chavas que formaban
parte de un movimiento llamado body
positive o cuerpo positivo en el que
entre otras cosas subían fotos del antes
y después o de cómo se vería bien en la
sociedad pero como son ellas realmente
cuerpos reales cuerpos imperfectos como
ustedes y como yo el estar viendo estas
imágenes constantemente en lugar del de
las delgadas modelos
hizo que empezara a aceptar el reflejo
que veía en el espejo porque me di
cuenta que se reflejó era de una persona
que estaba luchando por aceptarse y
amarse tal cual es y eso es lo que
necesitamos una red de apoyo que nos
contenga en los momentos de mayor
debilidad
y ya el último punto es el quinto y es
la manera en que nos comunicamos la
forma en que nuestros padres y los
adultos nos hablan desde pequeños
impacta hasta que crecemos
pareces una princesa eres un campeón
estas frases nos crean roles y
expectativas de cómo debemos ser y pues
nos sigue hasta la actualidad
y yo les pregunto cuántas veces han
halagado a una mujer sin enfocarse en su
aspecto físico
y a un nombre por sus logros postura de
poder fuerza física
la lista es interminable porque es
cambiar toda una cultura occidental en
la que vivimos pero la manera de empezar
es por nosotros mismos cuando decidí
mandar a mis voces internas y las
externas a la chingada
fue cuando empecé a conocerme realmente
como soy la verdad era jimena y empecé a
conseguir esta libertad que desde
pequeña había estado buscando aceptando
mis cachetes mis lonjitas mi estatura
mis habilidades y mi falta de ellas
hoy en día puedo decir que desde los 12
años he vivido con bulimia y que no me
avergüenzo en absoluto
pues cada día y cada caída ha
significado un nuevo aprendizaje y ha
sido parte de mi proceso al
empoderamiento
así que yo nos invitó hablemos
compartamos disfrutemos empatizamos pero
principalmente si lo necesitamos pidamos
ayuda y alcemos la voz muchas gracias